I loved what I saw but excuse me for
wanting to see when I would be playing
these games now I can understand the
concept and the reason they don't show
release dates right now that's fine but
I could still be disappointed I didn't
see them just like you guys some of you
are disappointed that Indiana Jones is
in a third person action adventure game
I could be disappointed that I didn't
see a release date on that game that we
are referring to doesn't mean I ain't
going to play the game doesn't mean I
ain't going to enjoy play what I saw it
just means that I wanted a little bit
more more concrete on what I was seeing
at the time of that release date now we
could get it and another reason that I
feel very strong about this because if
we ain't seeing a release date now call
nine times out of 10 what does that mean
mean it could be a chance of moving
around it could be a chance to no it
means we seen the majority of these
games in the June showcase again so oh
okay you think okay I see what you say
Okay so